- About to answer
some of your most unique
medical questions.
You got some good ones for me today.
Huge thanks to Walgreens
for sponsoring this video.
Let's get started.
Peewoop.
What's a subject you wish your professors
had spent more time focusing on
when they were teaching you in med school?
Okay. Okay.
Hotly contested subject.
The one thing I would add,
a monthly improv class
where you have to live in the
moment without preparation.
Just be there,
be a person,
speak your feelings.
Just yell at each other.
(yells)
(beeping)
Does drinking the recommended
amount of water per day
throughout the day
have the same impact on your body
as if you just chugged it
all in one or two sittings?
It's not the same.
Your body can only absorb so much water
and if it doesn't absorb it,
it then goes to waste
and you create urine.
(whooshing)
Which is more important,
inhaling or exhaling?
Okay. This is important.
Inhaling.
(chuckles)
Inhaling or ex-
(heaving breathing)
Honestly, as important it is to inhale.
I think the exhale is the underrated
because you can really
get a lot from an exhale.
I don't wanna go too spiritual with it
but it cleanses the soul.
(twinkle sounding)
And essentially when you're inhaling,
you're getting oxygen.
Yeah. Okay. Good stuff.
But when you're exhaling.
(exhaling)
Carbon dioxide.
Co2.
C-O-O-L.
Cool
(chuckles)
(static sounding)
"Wait, does Dr. Mike have a discord?
There are discord icons on
some of these questions."
Yeah, I have a discord, baby!
Join the Patreon.
You get automatic invite to the Discord.
And the Patreon is 10 bucks a month.
I keep none of the money.
Each month,
you vote where money goes to
the charity of your choice.
We have a monthly live stream.
We always have fun.
You get early access to tickets, to merch.
By the way, merch down below.
"Have you kept up your diet
after your last boxing match?"
Furthest from it.
In fact, someone from the
Discord sent me a chocolate bar.
I ate the whole chocolate bar just now.
I'm not proud of it,
but I'm human and I make mistakes
and this was today's mistake.
"Why does cutting my hand with scissors
hurt less than a paper cut?"
Oh, that's such a good question.
First of all,
I don't think that's true.
Just saying as a doctor.
I think just the paper
cut is less expected.
Like if scissors are cutting you,
you expect large amounts of pain
so you kind of prepare for it.
But just like getting a hit unexpectedly,
like getting sucker punch or
something hurts much worse,
a paper cut,
you're like,
"Oh, this is a paper.
No big deal."
Ugh, it cut me!
That ugh-it-cut-me
moment could be an issue.
Our pain perception is not
solely decided by the injury
but also our perception of the injury.
We basically have like a volume
remote of our pain signals.
But if we can learn to dial
down the volume on the pain,
we can get a better control of it
without taking medications.
"I love the smell of scent candles.
Please tell me,
is there any health benefit to them
or do they just smell good?"
Well, they just smell good.
But when you look good and you smell good,
you might feel good.
And there's health
benefits to feeling good.
I don't know why I just went
Matthew McConaughey on that.
"What would happen if you got
dust in your bloodstream?"
(smirks)
She'll be dusty.
(beeping)
I don't know, your macrophages
would probably eat it.
I don't know.
Ask a pathology channel.
Is seltzer water
unhealthier than flat water?
Oh man.
The reality about sparkling water
is the only population
of people that I say
should be careful with sparkling water
are people who have acid reflux.
Because if you already have some acid
leaking outside the
gut into the esophagus,
having bubbles in there,
you could actually expand the stomach more
and cause more of that leaky gut,
especially with burping and stuff.
Then everything else,
it's kind of not so bad.
It might be slightly more
acidic than tap water,
especially if it has some
like flavorings in it.
But dentists say like if
you drink it with a meal
or if you drink some water right after it,
like plain water, you're fine.
If you're replacing soda,
like sugary soda with seltzer,
dang right it's good for you.
"Is Dr. Mike expecting a child?
Because these dad jokes
are getting outta hand."
(rimshot drumming)
I'm having a baby.
(cricket chirping)
I don't have a good dad joke for that.
(crew member laughing)
(smirks)
(beeping)
But I am expecting.
(cricket chirping)
Expecting you to laugh at these dad jokes.
(rimshot drumming)
I saved that one.
(crew member laughing)
(static sounding)
Floorednow72 ask,
"Is it too late to get my flu shot?"
Well, I'm not exactly sure
when this question came in.
But as I'm answering
this question right now,
no, it's not too late.
You can still go get your flu shot.
That's actually one of the reasons
I was so excited to partner with Walgreens
who offer online and same day
scheduling for vaccinations/
Like updated COVID-19 boosters,
flu shots,
and so much more.
Staying healthy during the cold
winter months can be tricky
because of the chilly air.
They can dry out your mucus membranes.
Which leads to damage
where viruses and bacteria
can enter the body,
your lips, your nose.
Getting these vaccines is
not only important to me
because I wanna stay healthy,
but also because I see many people
who are immunocompromised.
So getting my shots helps
them stay safer too.
Walgreens pharmacists
have safely administered
over a hundred million vaccines
in the last three years.
They're professional, friendly,
and available to answer
all your vax questions.
As well as provide guidance
on which ones you may need.
Get started on
walgreens.com/schedulevaccine
by booking your COVID-19 booster
and flu shot appointments now.
"Are there any benefits
to having one blood type over another
outside of the ability to donate?"
We have seen some patterns
about certain illnesses happening less
and more often in certain blood types
but nothing that we found
that we can really act upon.
First of all,
what useful information is that for you?
You're not gonna change your blood type.
Maybe you can change
your certain activities
around certain things
'cause you know you're more susceptible.
But are you?
You know being on your
phone isn't that healthy.
I see you doing a little
risk reduction though
watching a doctor and stuff,
answer medical questions.
So you're growing up here.
But I see you.
"How many times a year
do you encounter a live
animal in the hospital?"
Live animal?
You mean like besides the
Supporting Paws Program
with like dogs?
I mean like flies.
Are they animals?
Is a fly animal.
Sam.
- [Sam] A fly would be an insect.
- But is that an animal?
- [Sam] I believe insects are animals.
- Are they?
- [Sam] Let's see.
Insects are the most
diverse group of animals.
- Ah-ha.
We caught you insect.
(Same distinctly talking)
Peewoop
(beeping)
"How you do clean Bear's ears?"
I actually have a full grooming video
where I groom Bear for like five hours.
I use like these ear wipes,
these medicated ear wipes.
I think it does a great job.
There's also things that
you could put in the ear,
kind of squish the ear around
and then let bear shake his ear out
to get the the liquid out.
"Oh wow, you pronounced Pelmeni correctly.
You really are Russian."
Yeah, I love Pelmeni is my favorite food.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, oh.
(beeping)
"My mother told me to never
stretch in the morning
or I will stunt my growth.
Is she telling the truth?"
Say what?
Stretch.
It's good.
I'm not a huge fan of stretching cold.
I like stretching after a
little bit of a dynamic warmup.
See, you might have a medical condition
and your mom bet this doctor
knows what he's talking about
'cause you have this medical condition?
Say what?
(beeping)
For the general person,
you stretch in the morning.
Props.
"What kind of music
does Dr. Mike listen to?
What is your Spotify wrapped say?"
I will give you three of my
songs on my Spotify raft 2022.
Song number one,
Mount Everest.
Which was my walkout song to
my boxing journey with iDubbbz.
Number two,
City of God's.
Mostly because of Alicia
Keys singing up in New York.
And then last but not least,
a little Sticky with Drake.
If you know, you know.
(whooshing)
"Is it unhealthy for me
to never take my bra off?
I wear 24/7 because I'm
uncomfortable when I have it on."
24/7 I would say is probably unnecessary.
If something's bothering you pain wise,
definitely a reason to see your doctor
even if you're younger.
Because it's easy enough
to get an ultrasound
and make sure that it's nothing serious.
Remember, I would much rather
you come in with a concern.
We not only rule it out anything dangerous
therefore we give you some reassurance,
but then we also can make sure
that we have a good line of communication.
We can give you some risks,
things that you're doing
that may be unhealthy
that could cause problems
down the line and act early.
There's very few things
we can act early upon
but if we use the tools that we have,
we can really extend not
only the length of our lives
but the quality of our lives.
"Why aren't over-the-counter
medication dosages
based on weight?
They're only based on whether
you're a kid or an adult."
Well, it matters more when you're a kid.
Weight-based dosages.
As an adult,
you have a healthy liver and kidney
so that like you have
normal functioning organs.
There's also a really important takeaway.
Plan B.
A medication that you use
as emergency contraception
may not work as well
in those are who are over
a certain number of pounds.
So please be aware of that
and speak to your doctor
about that situation.
I've seen people not know that
and then make some bad decisions.
Or at least incorrect
decisions about their health.
"I know under sleeping
is bad for my health,
but what about oversleeping?
If I sleep too much,
can it be harmful?
Sometimes I sleep in late
and somehow feel more tired."
That's actually a classic thing
and I talked about it with
Matthew Walker on my podcast.
Where if you're making up sleep debt,
where you haven't slept
for a certain number of nights in a row,
the adequate numbers of sleep,
and then you finally get
a good night's sleep.
That initial few minutes of waking up,
you're gonna feel terrible
because of sleep inertia.
Where you haven't yet kind
of cleared that sleep debt
and you probably need to
sleep a few more nights
in order to start feeling better.
"I heard if you're having
breakouts on your forehead
it's because of bad gut health.
Is this true and how can
I improve my gut health?"
Okay, I'm gonna take the second
part of the question first.
You can improve your gut health
by focusing on the things
we talk about quite often in this channel.
Eating fibrous foods,
those are basically prebiotics.
Eating a wide variety of plants,
AKA fruits and vegetables.
Limiting the amount of
simple sugars you consume
because those things can
actually worsen gut health.
Now let's talk about acne on the forehead.
Maybe if you're eating
a really unhealthy diet,
also having a really unhealthy lifestyle,
and not sleeping in all these things,
yeah you might get a breakout
because of a hormonal issue.
But it changing just one little aspect
is not gonna have a drastic
outcome on your skin.
You need to think about all
the variables in your life
and try and improve your lifestyle
as opposed to finding a hack here.
That's not the secret.
"What's the difference
between a first, second,
and third degree burn?"
Depth.
(typing)
First degree burns
only affect the outer layer of the skin.
Second degree burns
affect outer and underlying layer of skin.
And third degree burns
affect the deep layers of the skin.
See, I even had to look that up
even though the answer was
outer, outer and inner, or deep.
(chuckles)
But see, this is stuff at med school
that you shouldn't spend hours memorizing
'cause what ends up happening
is you learn a lot of useless information
that you could look up real quick.
And that's what the new generation
of medical student and doctor should be.
Someone that knows a lot,
but knows things that they can forget
that they can look up real quick.
'Cause the ease of information
is right there at our fingertips.
So for example,
guidelines change all the time
when it comes to screenings.
I try not to memorize those
because I know that at any
moment I can look it up
and get the most up-to-date info.
Even if I know it cold,
I still look it up cause I want to be sure
that I'm giving you the
best healthcare advice.
(tune sounding)
(rhythmic music)
I answered questions on the street.
Well not at the street but in Central Park
and they asked me tough ones too.
Huge thanks to Walgreens
for sponsoring this video.
Schedule an appointment online
at walgreens.com/schedulevaccine
and as always stay happy and healthy.